good morning belief nation today we're
going to talk about how you can overcome
pain pain is temporary it may last for a
minute or an hour or a day or even a
year but eventually it will subside and
something else will take its place if I
quit however it will last forever listen
to me I'm telling you as I leave I'm
telling you as I leave I was homeless
for two and a half years and the problem
with most of you you never felt no pain
before y'all spoil y'all spoil some of
y'all spoil just bottom-line your
parents have done everything for you you
never had to do nothing for yourself
you're spoiled we're gonna keep it real
tonight some of your spoiled brats every
time you ever got in trouble somebody
your house got you out of it every time
you've done something you not supposed
to do people say Eric your mother's a
tyrant you're right she kicked me out
you're right she's mean but she
developed a man because she put me out
there and said you're gonna have to grow
up and some of you have never learned to
grow up and so every time something get
hard you quit you call mama I dare you
to take a little pain I dare you I dare
you not to go home so my said Ike I'm
going home I feel bad go throw it you
ain't gonna die at the end of pain and
success you're not gonna die because
you're feeling a little pain I'm not
eating like I eat at home that's why you
brought to go through the next level
because if you keep eating like you had
at home you will keep being a boy or a
girl it's time to become a woman
so don't worry about a little pain
Payne is a beautiful thing Challenge is
what life is about a life without
challenge a life without pain is a life
without growth and where there is no
growth there stale stagnant energy and
that's where most people live because
most people's lives are designed around
treading a path that is void of
challenge the minute they recognize
challenge or pain they move the other
way this is a primal instinct and normal
and natural but a weak perspective most
people are bored if you ask them what do
you think about your life the same old
same old every single day what it was
the thing same day same [ __ ] different
day things of this nature that's because
they're living their lives in a lie that
is shrouded in comfort it doesn't exist
they're not challenged they're not
growing they're bored and they're better
off dead your likeness is found in your
pain embrace it love it and grow from it
there's science coming out research
coming out now that says when you talk
about your pain you release the energy
the pain head that was within you so
what do people do again they stuff down
their pain and then they wonder why they
get ill but it's because all of that
emotional energy was stuffed down into
into the unconscious and what you really
want to do is tool number two in number
two after journaling is talking find a
trusted adviser find a great friend you
know in difficult times you get to
understand who your greatest friends
truly are when I've gone through
difficult times some of the people I
thought were my greatest friends not
intentionally but they were busy in
their own lives what I most needed me
and so find that friend who you can talk
to and really open yourself up and take
down that social mass because talking
allows you to release that emotional
pain
and move through that emotional pain so
you do not repress that emotional pain
and you know what it's not only illness
that repression and suppression causes
you block your creativity you block your
humanity your contract your heart you
close your mind when you take all of
that pain and you pretend it's not there
because guess what it is there and one
of the reasons there are so much anger
out on the streets one of the reasons
there's so much toxicity in the
workplace is because of people who
repress the pain and they think it's not
there because they don't feel it because
they've escaped from it but it's in
their subconscious I didn't get here I
didn't get to where I am today I didn't
get here because you know I'm just
deeper or because just good things
happen to me I'm gonna tell y'all the
truth
I'm gonna tell you before y'all met me
right I'm gonna tell you I had to I had
a dream job of my life I was at a job
that I wanted to be at for the rest of
my life I had two kids and you hear me
the first one I got fired from man you
better hear what I'm telling you
the second one it was so toxic I had to
walk away listen to me closely listen to
Manila there was a time in my life right
I went to work and I stayed in my room I
cut the lights off unless the student
came to see me I was listening to my
music I pray like I never prayed before
I spend more time with God more time in
the world and said to me I have pain
gone I felt sabotage there are some
people who I felt they were out to get
me are you hear what I'm saying
they wanted me gone you talk about
haters and I went through this for a
whole year are you hearing what I'm
saying
I'm talking about sabotage I'm talking
about pain I'm talking about
I did what things I didn't want to get
up there was days that I'm gonna put my
clothes on there was days I didn't want
to face the world are you hearing what
I'm saying
but I realized when I look back at it
all what God was telling me is you stuck
on good huh you got the best two jobs in
your life you got your dream job sir but
this is only the beginning this is not
the end this is not where I want you to
be for the rest of your life and so I
was blessed because I went through so
much pain that that pain actually pushed
me ah you better hear what I'm telling
you today I'm telling you the death
hey push me to prosperity that pain
pushed me to Crichton is that pay okay
okay all right
I gotta help you understand right I've
been talking about writing the book
listen to me very closely I have been
talking about writing a book for 10
years but guess what guess what when I
left the job when I left that job when I
left that dream child with the 401 K
when I left that dream job whilst
getting paid well as making the
difference in students life when I left
the dream job I said to myself I will
never go back to this again I will never
deal with the stuff that I dealt with
before I left that job and just right
afterwards I wrote the book you're not
here when I'm telling y'all for 10 years
my story didn't change I didn't even
write about my experience once I got to
Michigan State universe I never wrote
about that I wrote about what happened
before that
but I procrastinated but guess what when
I walked away from that job I said I
will never be treated like that again I
will never go through what I went
through again and that pain pushed me to
write a best-seller now you hear what
I'm saying I did my homework y'all I
found out Adele Adele did the album 21
it was the best album it was the best
single it was the best song do you hear
what I'm saying it was the best record
she won six Grammys you're not here when
I'm telling y'all but have you done your
homework have you done your research you
were discovering 21 there was a point
that she stopped she lost her creativity
she couldn't come up with songs she
couldn't come up with thoughts she
couldn't find anything original but then
she did her man dump dump with somebody
else
are you hearing what I'm telling you and
that pain she went through pain and that
pain pushed her back in the studio and
that pain perdu six Grammys that pain
produced top album top single top song
go you hear what I'm telling you I'm
telling you you going through pain I
know what you feel it I know exactly
been there I've done that but you gotta
work through it and if you work through
your pain on the other side is a reward
listen to me
pain a permanent oh you better hear what
I'm telling you you're paying a
permanent you're playing a permanent you
can get through this you bring it in
your
you better than that let me tell you
something when I left both of those jobs
I made up in my mind
each is you gonna work through this
you're gonna get up you're gonna get
dressed you won't get out and you're
gonna you can you can do what you being
called to do you're gonna be what you
called me you're gonna have and you're
gonna prove that everybody that try to
break you you gonna prove a room
everybody trying to stop you everybody
that tried to kill your dream you're
gonna prove all of them wrong
are you hearing what I'm saying I didn't
get here today hey man I didn't get here
today because of the reason you thought
I got here I got here I got here with
pain that's right a couple of weeks from
now the NFL baby I got gigs with the NFL
I got gigs with Major League Baseball
are you hearing what I'm telling you I'm
in schools
I'm in college is I'm coming I'm coming
you probably even or football team
baseball [ __ ] I'm coming basket I'm
coming to your car
let's go Browns in the airport some kid
tweeted me I'm an airport he like yo kid
you ain't gonna believe this
I'm in the same Airport with et but
listen to me very closely I didn't get
to where I wanted to be I'm finally
where I wanted to be but I had to go
through some pain to get there and so to
my boss man I'm telling you I love I
love him I love him I love him if I
could go back man I'm telling you I'd
say thank you I'd say thank you for
everything you put me through because
you pushed me out of good and you forced
me into greatness I was gonna stay at
those jobs I would still be there today
I wouldn't be in Egypt I've been to
Egypt I got an invite to Australia I'm
coming to the UK I got a best-seller I'm
coming up with a clothing line are you
hearing what I'm telling you your boy eg
I use the pay to push me to greatness
and I'm telling you right now don't give
up I'm telling you right now don't give
me get through it and if you can get
through if you can work through your
praying if you can work through your pay
I'm guaranteeing you on the other side
is a reward pain is not permanent pain
is temporary the key is what we do in
our times of pain pain will change us
heartache loss disappointments they
don't leave us the same when I lost my
father I didn't come out like I was
before I was changed
if you go through a divorce a legal
battle a friend betrays you eventually
that will pass you'll get through it but
you will be different now how the pain
changes you is up to you you can come
out bitter or you can come out better
you can come out with a chip on your
shoulder blaming God or you can come out
stronger with a greater confidence in
God you can come out defeated giving up
on your dreams or you can come out with
a new passion a new fire excited about
the new opportunities in front of you
all of us experience pain my challenge
don't just go through it grow through it
that difficulty is an opportunity to get
stronger to develop character to gain
new confidence anybody can give up
anybody can let it overwhelm you but you
know what that's doing wasting your pain
that pain is not there to stop you it's
there to prepare you to increase you to
develop you pain is necessary it's
inescapable it's no way out of pain we
are born pain is a must pain it is a
necessity of growth be comfortable with
being uncomfortable pain is a necessary
evil get used to it
make friends with it and then kick it
pains pass and that way when it comes to
take you down and burster job I'm used
to you bring it on come on paint 6os
down and let's have lunch together me
and you pay let's do it
best friends
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I made this video
because each age and good fella asked me
to so if there's a topic you'd like me
to cover in the next addition to believe
life leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know what you took from this video what
was most helpful what was most
interesting what change you're gonna
make how you deal with pain leave it in
the comments below and I hope to get a
good discussion going thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
journalling has saved my life I mean for
hundreds and hundreds of years people in
pain have pulled out a fresh blank sheet
of paper and poured their pain onto the
written page and now their science
coming out science is actually saying
when you journal about what's good in
your life even when you feel like
nothing's good in your life you actually
release all these neurotransmitters
which make you feel better you've heard
me say this before perhaps gratitude is
the antidote to pain and so journaling
where you process through your pain I
mean the worst thing you can do is what
society suggests that you do escape get
busy forget about it lose yourself and
work of course you have to work of
course you have to show up your team
needs you life needs you your family
needs you life is for the living I got
it but I don't believe that the answer
to get through your pain is to escape in
your pain and too many people do that
and I've read the books that say to do
that you can't motivate yourself out of
heartbreak you've got to feel yourself
through the heartbreak I mean I think
it's that old Alaniz the the old Elena
Alanis Morissette song the quickest way
out is in and the wisest amongst us get
that but most people don't
they literally numb themselves to the
pain and then they wonder why five years
later they have a heart attack ten years
later they end up with cancer and so
journaling allows you to process through
the pain there are gifts in pain there
is glory in pain that's how you develop
the bravery that's how you develop the
humanity when I've gone through the most
difficult times that I'm in pain I use
it as a servant and it makes me humble
when the ego starts screaming pain shuts
down that ego pretty quickly and you
look at the greatest amongst us they
have endured the most suffering
sufferings not a bad thing
suffering is an awesome thing the world
just says to us it puts a label on
suffering but you're going to get better
if you
strong suffering to your advantage so
journaling is a tool where you actually
get the process through the pain write
about your heartbreak or write about
your confusion or write about your hurt
or write about your misunderstanding
write about the fact that you think it's
never going to end
write about your blessings write about
your talents write about what's good in
your life because even in the worst
feeling life you have daylight and you
want to focus on that daylight is it
possible for everybody who has the pain
to be able to stop it
absolutely absolutely pain is not normal
it really isn't is it well it may be
normal it's not natural it's not next
not natural okay it's normal for us in
this society to live in pain and to mask
it the call is something else people
will say oh don't feel like that
do you mean don't feel too late I told
you you laughter okay too late it's too
late I feel like this will you telling
me though that is not helpful okay you
did tell me all people say oh don't do
that that's not right that's not nice
how you gonna do that so you know these
are the ways that we talk our pain down
we mask it and and a friend of mine
Reverend Deborah L Johnson she put it
this way in order to heal the pain you
gotta feel it
deal with it and heal it feel deal heal
if you don't feel it feel it from the
core of your being
some people are numb to it that's right
yeah drop your hands to the side
remember we did this in my class call up
the guilt the shame the fear the
insecurity the inadequacy huge
inadequacy yes a saying that people
don't often talk about you know
inadequacy call it up feel it feel it in
your being be with it have you ever
watched a James Bond movie before it
doesn't look like he's losing at some
point and then he wins or Batman or Iron
Man or any superhero there has to be
some diversity for you to you know
overcome to win no it can't be a champ
unless you uh you know are in a place
where you look like you're gonna lose
and then you win the pain that's gonna
come with being independent you have to
embrace it because it's gonna happen and
also know that the more successful you
get the more problems you're gonna have
the more not you're gonna have bad time
being a boss does not mean smooth
sailing it means having the ability to
care about other people before yourself
and to untie problems untie knots that's
all it is there's it's not business if
there's that problem there's nothing
good without struggle it just doesn't
happen and all my experiences there
hasn't been one thing that's been
successful without me feeling some pain
before it was successful so now when
there is pain I embrace it you know I've
been embracing it I Maji about it
because I know that must mean that if
I'm cool yeah you know what awaits me is
like the darkest before the dawn I don't
I don't want to like sound corny but
that's really what that's that's what
has to happen